Tổng thức kể như tổng máu tổng máu, nhóm lý là có phòng của khuôn nha sẽ chia hàng tránh trở đúng là Mỹ để mua vô kỳ của Mỹ,
thông qua sẵn kiến xanh một yêu cầu ước tiền của quen á, thông bảo đu đu dân ra sau của học nhóm lý là,
lúc tại Rúc Sén, bởi vì hóa hình cái đồng bói từ anh,
Aislang, Nà Ui, Thuy Giện, Bölipa, dú bố khuôn nha tăng cường nữ phòng thủ.
Tất quan ra phá cũng đang tân nhắc bầu xung kinh phy để mua thông bố kỳ Mỹ chủ khuôn nha.
Nà Ui và pháp đã kiế thuật thuần điện trở bao gồm bong giấm đường,
Bà thí bị giám xác, với giả trị lên lượt là bón cho 1 người phy nâm trở đối là Mỹ và bà trăm người bốn trở đối là Mỹ bảo lãnh,
Đứa cũng sẽ cùng gấp hình nâm tên lợn đánh trận pháp bà,
Nếu các nước khác tại trở bà mươi tên lợi này,
Ngai nhiều lần cạnh báo rằng việc xung tây cùng gấp bố kỳ chủ khu khu khu khu nha,
có thể cảm trở đủ lực giả của xung đột,
và khiến đa tôn trở thành một bên trong khuôn hoàn,
ngoài trường sẽ kể là vô bình dẫn mạnh cái trường hành bố kỳ sẽ là một tư ở pháp của của đổi nha.
Trúc khi phía nó tốt hợp lệnh cảm kế phố trở khiem,
Bà đảm nâng lợn phòng thu.